hi yeah
so
yes
you're
so
nice
hey
fun if you have a free outline you can
plug
[Music]
um
um
okay
beautiful
um
okay
beautiful thank you give me a second
sure
you can do downward
make me angry
[Music]
too much on that
but it seems like it's
maybe over christmas or thanksgiving
but i'll put it right here
besides the play
is
appreciate it
hot in here
all right exactly
hey
thank you greg
good dog
[Music]
look at the no look at the map
no look at the list below that camera no
the camera you just touched
that's the list that's who is centered
last time
okay good done thank you
so you gotta rotate everything
sure
check one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten check
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
probably a little bit down from there
michaela i'm hearing it now check one
two three four five
six seven eight nine ten one two
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten good
i think that's better
okay
[Music]
hey
uh
so cold
tracking
okay
[Applause]
audio test testing 123 audio test test
oh
yeah
i'm getting one of those
is
thank you sir
ready yep
um
sit
good
is
that's my middle name not even my
nickname my parents gave me that name
it's a nice german name yeah
and just as soon as those remotes are
out of my way i'll be able to sit down
again
there you go hey
sorry
okay
i was there
is
thank you
is
i don't know
[Music]
that in addition to everything else
going on with the election there are
some coded restrictions
in the white house that's why we just uh
and in addition to some of the gloom
in multiple states across the country to
try to stop this biden victory
and in the words of this trump advisor
not the way i want to win
so there are some inside the campaign
who would like to win this the
old-fashioned way
by tallying up the votes and seeing who
wins who has the most votes
obviously there are some people inside
the campaign and the president may be
leading the charge on this who feels
that he is being robbed
and so therefore he has to do what he
has to do
in court now obviously you know that is
not aligned with the facts we heard the
pennsylvania secretary of state speak
this for a while again saying
she has not seen any uh instances of
voter fraud as we know historically
there has been a widespread voter fraud
in the us but the president is going to
try to defend reality
then the facts about the truth and his
direction in the hopes of
uh trying to make something happen on
the legal front the other the other
thing that is
confounding this campaign and it's going
to be a problem for them when they get
into court is that they are arguing for
the stoppage of counting
in some states and arguing for the
continuing of counting in other states
that's obviously
something that is going to be a giant
red flag you know pointed out by any
judge uh when the trump lawyer is going
to court and so i suspect
anderson when the president comes in
here he's going to want to make a
statement
uh he is going to want to look like he's
in charge he's been watching joe biden
go out there
and make these sort of statesman like
statements over the last couple of days
and the president wants i think to
reclaim the mantle to reclaim the oval
office for something so here
and we'll wait and see if the president
wants to take any questions there's
obviously a lot on our minds
in terms of what we want to ask for such
as for example
why not continue to count the votes
that's what we do in the strength
i think so yes they do not have a
consistent
position they want to continue counting
in states where
uh perhaps he might be able to you got
to win and they want to stop counting
and saying he's in trouble um and that
you know i think most americans will
look at that and just see that as being
uh something that just doesn't stand up
and you know but the president
is watching the lights go out on his
presidency
that's what we're witnessing in real
time as these votes are being
tabulated
um
is
um
sometime in the next few minutes
right this is
that margins
um
and the president i suspect is very
frustrating about this
summit all capsules
he wants to get around coming out of the
pokemon having us
uh those those types of restrictions and
so i suppose in addition to the
presidential seal being slapped on that
lecture behind me
would probably ought to be a surgeon
general what you're about to hear
something
right
there were thousands of people who were
out there and the weather was cold
city rochester minnesota they limited it
to 250 in the actual event
but there were thousands of people who
were waiting outside just to show their
support so
i'm not sure that this idea of
suppression cold
actually worked in the real world but
you know the president's got a case
i i truly believe that the polling was
so horribly inaccurate for the most part
as it was in 2016 that our senate people
on again
the people on the campaign trail yeah
a better chance to really figure it out
should run
biden to have the news cycle because his
campaign surrogates were out there
um they were very sort of leading the
charge to the president in terms of
where this was going to go
as far as the vote count goes as far as
the lawsuits go
they were fighting i was told yesterday
that brighton
um
don't forget as these races tighten
a lot of attention on arizona
but if he loses okay so um
so the fact that the margin was in
georgia is extraordinary i've lived
there for
five six years in fact i saw that i saw
the ton of nintendo
the democratic graphic makeup and the
politics
okay it please
[Music]
i've
[ __ ]
hilarious
oh
that's
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
okay
i'm
okay
[Music]
oh
robertson yeah
thank you
reminder if you do not have a seat in
the briefing room you are not
allowed in the briefings two minute
morning guys two minutes
down
here we go
[Music]
mr
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
good evening i'd like to provide the
american people with an update on our
efforts
to protect the integrity of our very
important 2020 election
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
i've already decisively won many
critical states including massive
victories in florida
iowa indiana ohio to name just a few
we won these and many other victories
despite historic
election interference from big media big
money and big tech
as everybody saw we won by historic
numbers and the pollsters got
it knowingly wrong they got it knowingly
wrong we had polls that were so
ridiculous
and everybody knew it at the time there
was no blue wave that they predicted
they thought there was going to be a big
blue wave that was false that was done
for
suppression reasons but instead there
was a big
red wave and it's been properly
acknowledged actually by the media they
were
i think very impressed but that was
after the fact that doesn't do us any
good
we kept the senate despite having twice
as many seats to defend as democrats
and in a really much more
competitive states we've uh we did a
fantastic job with the senate i think
we're very proud of what's
happened there with many more seats to
defend they spent almost
200 million dollars on senate races in
south carolina and kentucky alone
two races and hundreds of millions of
dollars
overall against us at the national level
our opponents major donors were
wall street bankers and special
interests our major donors were police
officers farmers everyday citizens
yet for the first time ever we lost zero
races in the house
i was talking to kevin mccarthy today he
said he couldn't believe it
zero races very unusual thing zero and
actually won many new seats
with i think many more on the way this
was
also the year of the republican woman
more republican women were elected to
congress than
ever before that's a great achievement i
won the largest share of non-white
voters of any republican in 60 years
including historic
numbers of latino african-american
asian-american and native american
voters
the largest ever in our history
we grew our party by 4 million voters
the greatest turnout
in republican party history
democrats are the party of the big
donors the big media the big tech
it seems and republicans have become the
party of the american worker and that's
what's happened
and we're also i believe the party of
inclusion
as everyone now recognizes media polling
was
election interference in the truest
sense of
that word by powerful special interests
these really phony polls i have to call
them phony polls stake polls were
designed to keep our voters
at home create the illusion of momentum
for mr biden and diminished republicans
ability to raise funds
they were what's called suppression
polls everyone knows that now
and it's never been used to the extent
that it's been used on this last
election to highlight just a few
examples the day before
election quinnipiac which was wrong
on every occasion that i know of
had joe biden up by five points in
florida
and they were off by 8.4 points
and i won florida easily easily
so they had me
losing clara to buy a lot and i ended up
winning florida by a lot
other than that they were very accurate
they had
him up four points in ohio and they were
off by 12.2 points
and they also won ohio great state of
ohio
very easily the washington post had
buyed up 17 points in wisconsin
and it was basically even they were off
by about 17 points
and they knew that they're not stupid
people they knew that
suppression there are now only a few
states yet to be
decided in the presidential race the
voting
apparatus of those states are run in all
cases by democrats
we were winning in all the key locations
by a lot
actually and then our numbers started
miraculously getting whittled away
in secret and they wouldn't allow
legally permissible observers we went to
court
in a couple of instances and we were
able to get the observers put in and
when the observers got there they wanted
them
60 70 feet away 80 feet 100 feet away or
outside the building to observe
people inside the building and we won a
case a big case and
we have others happening a lot of lots
of litigation even beyond our litigation
there's tremendous
amount of litigation generally because
of how unfair this process was and i
predicted that i've been talking about
mail-in voting for a long time it's
it's really destroyed our system it's a
corrupt system
and it makes people corrupt even if they
aren't by nature
but they become corrupt it's too easy
they want to find out how many the votes
they need and then they seem to be able
to find them
they wait and wait and then they find
them and
you see that on election night we were
ahead in vote
in north carolina by a lot tremendous
number of votes
and we're still ahead by a lot but
not as many because they're finding
ballots all of a sudden no we have some
male in ballots it's amazing how those
maryland ballots are so one-sided too i
know that
it's supposed to be to the advantage of
the democrats but
in all cases they're so one-sided we
were up by nearly 700
000 votes in pennsylvania i won
pennsylvania by a lot
and that gets whittled down to i think
they said now we're up
by 90 000 votes and they'll keep coming
and coming and coming they find them all
over
and they don't want us to have any
observers although we want a court case
the judge said you have to have
observers likewise endure and they're
appealing
actually they're appealing we want a
case that we want
people to watch and we want observers
and they're actually appealing which is
sort of interesting i wonder why that
appeal that all we want to do is have
people watch
as they do the vote tabulations
likewise in georgia i won by a lot a lot
with a lead of over getting close to 300
000 votes on election night in georgia
and by the way got whittled down and now
it's getting to be
to a point where i'll go from winning by
a lot
to perhaps being even down a little bit
in georgia a pipe burst in a far away
location totally unrelated
to the location of what was happening
and they stopped counting
for four hours and a lot of things
happened
the election apparatus in georgia is run
by democrats we
also had margins of 300 000 and
michigan were way up in michigan won the
state
and in wisconsin we did likewise
fantastically well and uh that got
whittled down
every in every case they got whittled
down today we're on track to win
arizona we only need to carry i guess 55
percent
of the remaining vote 55 percent margins
and
that's a margin that we've significantly
exceeded so we'll see what happens with
that but we're on track to do okay in
arizona
our goal is to defend the integrity of
the election we'll not allow
the corruption to steal such an
important election or any election for
that matter
and we can't allow silence anybody to
silence our voters
and manufacture results i've never had
i've been doing
a lot of public things for a long time
i've never had anything that's been as
inspirational by people calling talking
sending things to us i've never
seen such such love and such affection
and such
uh spirit as i've seen for this people
know what's happening and they see
what's happening and it's before their
eyes
and there are many instances which will
be reported very shortly
there's tremendous litigation going on
and this is a case where they're trying
to steal an election
they're trying to rig an election and we
can't let that happen detroit and
philadelphia known as two of the most
corrupt political places anywhere in our
country
easily cannot be responsible for
engineering the outcome of
a presidential race a very important
presidential race in pennsylvania
democrats have gone
to the state supreme court to try and
ban our election observers
and very strongly now we won the case
but they're they're going forward they
don't want anybody in there they don't
want anybody watching them as they
count the ballots and i can't imagine
why there's
absolutely no legitimate reason
why they would not want to have people
watching this process because if it's
straight
uh they would be they should be proud of
it instead they're
trying obviously to commit fraud
uh there's no question about that in
philadelphia observers have been
kept far away very far away so far
that people are using binoculars to try
and see and there's been
tremendous problems caused they put
paper on all of the windows so you can't
see in and the people
that are banned are very unhappy and
become
somewhat violent the 11th circuit ruled
that in georgia the
votes have been in by
the election day that they should be in
by election day
and they weren't votes are coming in
after election day
and they had a ruling already that you
have to have the votes in by election
day to the best of my knowledge votes
should be in by election day
and they didn't do that democrat
officials never believed they could win
this election honestly i really believe
that that's why they did the mail-in
ballots where there's tremendous
corruption and fraud going on that's why
they
mailed out tens of millions of
unsolicited ballots without any
verification measures whatsoever
and i've told everybody that these
things would happen
because i've seen it happen i watched a
lot of different elections
before they decided to go with this big
massive
election with tens of millions of
ballots going out to
everybody in many cases totally
unsolicited this was unprecedented in
american history
this was by design despite years of
claiming to care about the election
security they refused to include any
requirement to verify
signatures identities or even determine
whether
they're eligible or ineligible to vote
people are walking in there they have no
idea they're just taking
the numbers they're writing down things
the workers and doing a lot of bad
things and we have a lot of
information coming and litigation that
you'll see that will
shake even your people up and you've
seen it all the officials overseeing
the counting in pennsylvania and other
key states are all part of a
corrupt democrat machine that you've
written about and
for a long time you've been writing
about the corrupt democrat machine
i went to school there and i know a lot
about it hasn't changed
a long time ago and hasn't changed it's
gotten worse
in pennsylvania partisan democrats have
allowed ballots in the state to be
received three days after the election
and we think much more than that and
they're counting those
without even postmarks or any
identification
whatsoever so you don't have postmarks
you don't have identification
there have been a number of disturbing
irregularities across the
nation our campaign has been denied
access to observe
any counting in detroit detroit is
another place
and uh i wouldn't say has the best
reputation
for election integrity workers in
michigan were duplicating ballots
but when our observers attempted to
challenge the activity those poll
workers
jumped in front of the volunteers to
block their views so that they couldn't
see what they were doing
and it became a little bit dangerous
one major hub for counting ballots in
detroit covered up the windows again
with large pieces of cardboard and
so they wanted to protect and block the
counting area they didn't want anybody
seeing the county even though these were
observers who were
legal observers that were supposed to be
there in detroit there were hours of
unexplained delay in delivering many of
the votes for counting
the final batch should not arrive until
four in the morning
and uh even though the polls closed at
eight o'clock so they brought it in
and the batches came in and nobody knew
where they came from
we've also been denied access to observe
in critical places in georgia
and multiple swing states counting was
halted for hours
and hours on election night with results
withheld from
major democrat-run locations only to
appear
later and they certainly appeared and
they all had the name biden on them or
just about all i think almost all they
all had the name biden on them
which is a little strange i challenge
joe and every democrat to
clarify that they only want legal votes
because they talk about votes and i
think they should use the word legal
legal votes
we want every legal vote counted and i
want every legal vote counted we want
openness and transparency no secret
count rooms
no mystery ballots no illegal votes
being cast after election day you have
election day and the laws are very
strong on that you have an election day
and they don't want votes cast after
election day and
they want the process to be an honest
one it's so important
we want an honest election we want an
honest count
and we want honest people working back
there because it's a very important job
so
that's the way this country is going to
win that's the way the united states
will win
and we think we will win the election
very easily we think there's going to be
a lot of litigation because we have so
much evidence so much proof
and it's going to end up perhaps at the
highest court in the land
we'll see but we think there'll be a lot
of litigation because we can't have
an election stolen like this and i i
tell you i would
i have been talking about this for many
months with all of you
and i've said very strongly that mail-in
ballots are going to end up being a
disaster
small elections were a disaster small
very easy to handle elections
were disastrous this is a large-scale
version and it's getting worse and worse
every day we're hearing
stories that are horror stories absolute
horror stories
and we can't let that happen to the
united states of america it's not a
question of who wins republican democrat
joe myself we can't let that happen to
our country
we can't be disgraced by having
something like this happen
so it will be hopefully cleared up maybe
soon i hope soon
but it'll probably go through a process
a legal process and
as you know i've claimed certain states
and he's claiming states and we can both
claim the states but ultimately i have a
feeling judges are going to have to rule
but there's been a lot of shenanigans
and we can't uh stand for that in our
country
thank you very much
[Music]
you